right now you're being rewarded for
being a yes person and in 36 months
you're gonna be fired for being a yes
person the people that are gonna win
over the next five to seven years are
gonna be very comfortable in controlled
chaos so you better get your speed up
you may be thinking that I'm watching
the show but what I'm doing is what I
need to do just I'm reading your
comments
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out so you
can help change the world so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
from four-time New York Times
bestselling author and legendary
entrepreneur Gary Vaynerchuk and my take
on his top ten rules of success volume
three rule number three is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well
enjoy
it is far more fun to die on your sword
than to die on someone else's I'm
inspired YouTube we're gonna make this
the episode thing you'll get whatever
you want Tyler but this is the core of
it you just saw it on stage that's just
you just saw it on stage dying on your
sword is better than dying on someone
else's so many of you are doing things
making decisions and navigating your
lives based on somebody else's thesis
you're doing it because you think it's
the right thing because your dad's
telling you it's the right thing you're
doing what you're doing right now cuz
you're pandering to your boss even
though you don't believe in it this is
how it's gonna play out you are doing
things right now yesterday you made a
decision that you don't believe in but
you're smart you did it because you know
how your company scores here's the
problem with disruption and innovation
right now you're being rewarded for
being a yes person and in 36 months
you're going to be fired for being a yes
person and you're doing it because you
just need the security of your job I'm
telling you right now if you're watching
this vlog and you've got like that means
you have a certain DNA please I implore
you please die on your sword not
somebody else's if you're gonna lose
it's much more fun to lose based on what
you thought do you I mean do you know
how many of you are gonna lose on
somebody else's thesis it's gonna kill
at you it's gonna eat at you it's going
to be the worst feeling so please pause
this video right now and ask yourself am
i doing my because of me then you're
good whether you're winning or losing or
am i doing it because somebody else is
telling me it's the right way or I'm
subconsciously pandering to please
somebody or something because I need the
short-term stability figured out the gal
you know it and I know it you just need
to do something about it I really think
mindset is
and so you've got a really desiring any
positive about things like negative
nothing's am i thrilled that I have the
ability to do things about it to make
what I'm worried about better or my
crippled by there's like these set of
things like tomorrow I always choose
positivity I look at other people around
me it's not just about me that winning
they choose positivity I look at the
people around me that are not winning
that are not progressing that are not
advancing their issues and negativity
it's stunningly binary it's stunningly
black-and-white it's stunningly err me
this is really up to you and Billy to be
very honest to be very frank I think the
biggest impact I'm having is I'd be that
all the emails because I read aloud that
last night as well is is shifting that
mindset and getting people to that
understand what they're in charge of
that and hacking and trying to pour out
the negativity dump the negativity
[Music]
I'm a positivity to your world that's
what I'm pushing that's my agenda and
and that's why I think it really affects
and I
partner loved one in audience so many
people get 49 comments for me phenomenal
the ones like your piece and they spend
their time on that one the way I do
branding I sell so infrequently that I
think some of you that are watching me
the hardest core need to hear this which
is it's ok to sell especially if you
believe in something look if you believe
in what you're selling and that's what
I'm spending a lot of time on now trying
to spend more time on really getting to
a place where I really believe in stuff
instead of just passive not creating so
it wasn't selling because I didn't
believe you know and just letting
everything come to me but as I create
these you know events Vayner experience
a lot of events very big on events
events are so valuable just watching the
4 DS crew is value and like how it's
impacting their business for $10,000
right drag em and you see I know you get
the emails the wine club like $150 worth
one for 55 bucks like I've just locked
in November's it's gonna make all your
Thanksgivings ridiculous the conference
$500 two-hour session that in my
stomping grounds good deal compared to
like other conferences that I speak at
but you're giving the wine for free or
you're getting the talk too free and
you're getting the wine so like I'm very
fascinated because I'm putting more
pressure on myself to create things that
I really believe in which then allows me
to sell more and I just think for a lot
of you selling the ask the right hook is
very difficult you're passive you like
the idea of like feeling good about like
giving out content this and that when
you believe in something you can sell it
and you should put more pressure on
yourself to create things that you
believe in biggest problem is so many of
you self you don't believe in you're
just doing it for the money you're gonna
lose
not I don't like you maybe thinking that
I'm watching the show but what I'm doing
is what I need to do which is I'm
reading your comments to set it for all
the new ones that are here the comments
are my oxygen I don't think people
understand how much qualitative feedback
you get from comments reading comments
watching the explore pages looking at
how you guys respond to my stuff and
others there's so many hours of
consumption you know I don't this is
where I don't consume shows and things
of that nature because I spent so much
time reading reading reading reading
reading your feedback you I I as a
collective I consume you guys more than
you consume me and so I just highly
recommend when you have a small audience
like you read every one of those
comments you engage with every one of
those comments brick by brick by brick
eventually you can't reply to everybody
but like you can always read a lot I
mean I read I'm just reading all these
comments you know what I noticed the
Marion I want your opinion surest I I've
noticed that every idea that I've had
whether is a drum kit or the podcasts or
whatever it was passed the Ox good
they're all things that I felt like
would end up being really fun to do and
and so my kind of philosophy I'm
adopting now is like if it's fun fun
it's probably you know why that happens
it's a it's a bigger macro situation
because it's fun you're willing to work
your face off and working your face off
is actually the gateway it's not the fun
the fun is the doorway that gets you to
put in the work that gets you the
results because d-roc loves filming like
the 24/7 nature of what he does is you
know is why so many kids want to film
into this but they don't want to it's
not fun enough for them you have to love
it so the cost of entry now is you see
understand you have to love like for me
building brands whether it's my own
brand brands for other people other
things to why it's so the only thing I
gave a [ __ ] about that I'm willing to
put in the nineteen
that it takes because the problem is now
with the internet like we were just
saying being the middleman and everybody
can play there's some kid in Kansas City
who's gonna put in the 19 right my dad
put in 20 and I don't want any I don't
want any of you little should take my
now what's amazing as though the biggest
thing I didn't know is that's some fun
but there's so much that all those
little that are gonna put in the 19 are
gonna get theirs too and that makes me
happy yeah so I would say funds a great
gateway to fun is the precursor to
ridiculous amount of work which then
gets you there yeah right I think when I
get the praise
it's what the [ __ ] does that have to do
with me when I get it on I'm like that's
on me and I'll fix it and I think those
you know I was I said it really quick
but it's accountability it's
accountability and ownership when you
suck
it's passing on the credit and that's it
and that's me and that's my makeup and
that's why I'm winning in life that's
why I'm always gonna win because when
you're a hundred percent accountable
and you know your your garbage they're
100% accountable when there's an issue
and when you pass on the praise when
you're getting it
you become fundamentally under
unbeatable I'm straight-up unbeatable
because my head will never get gassed up
enough ever when I'm getting it good
and
and I'll never believe it's me and when
it's bad I'll never point the finger to
anybody else
boys finger pointers pointing everywhere
everybody pointing fingers tweeting them
everywhere everybody's property self
country the environment the parents
school system boss and circumstances
force and of course there's tragedies
and crimes and child abuse and real bad
stuff not saying it's not real you say
for the ninety five percent of you it's
a lie deceptive
perspective
records everything rounded in my
perspective
never to hide ever to love
it's about them what it's good to
that's me that's what I got for you
and I never waver 1% had my bad days
let me just talk to you guys about why
toys-r-us trip filing chapter 11 matters
toys-r-us did two things over the last
couple decades that make no sense one
very early in the 2000s they outsource
themselves to Amazon they didn't believe
in the internet 17 years ago so that
Amazon do their fulfillment which
started people getting used to buying
toys on the Internet through an Amazon
world but most importantly they just
didn't innovate you know and when you
don't innovate you die like you could
have made toys Twitter lost three years
ago could have created the National Lego
championships and everybody would be
there was a there was a million they
could have made slime centers they could
have they could be killing it right now
with their locations but no they choose
to just like sell toys out of it and
none of you want to go there first of
all you're gonna go to Walmart and pick
it up for less money anyway while you
pick up your groceries anything else and
if you even want to leave your home and
you don't and so you'll go to Amazon and
do it that way or buy it from somebody's
youtube channel link or you know
Instagram account it's just it's it's
the best example right now of like how
in trouble everybody is if they rest on
their laurels
you know if Toys R Us the dominant niche
retail leader of a humongous
multi-billion dollar category is
finished what do you think is gonna
happen over the next six years you have
to reverse engineer who you're trying to
get to you know if your sales person out
there right now if you're trying to get
to me and so many of you are I get 50 70
bulk emails bulk direct messages bulk
Twitter direct messages Instagram
business cards all sorts of weird stuff
sent in the mail I'm busy I'm busy and
like I'm just not interested in you
selling to me not because I don't like
you because I respect the game it's
because I'm just busy it's nothing
personal
so I think the first thing you have to
do is reverse engineer the person you
know because I'm not in the market to
buy anything I'm gonna be tougher but if
I need certain software if I need
something that's a good time to attack
right so I think the number one rule of
sales people is to listen know your
audience know what they did if you see
an M&A just happened if you see layoffs
just happening if you see one of their
come if I see
Burger King doing something I'm thinking
what does McDonald's think of Rus I
think a lot of you are doing things that
are directly in front of you
numbers that they put in front of you
you're trying to achieve that because
you have a beach house you want to buy
or go on that vacation sales is a funny
game if you work in a big company they
manipulate numbers to create your
actions I believe that the best
salespeople are doing things in a
different way I think you need to care
about the customer for real
reverse-engineer them and give them what
they need I put out a post about you
know stop blaming other people stop
right start blaming yourself leave in
comments right now it's super
fascinating
of course you you know so my whole thing
is like blame myself for everything of
course there's other things that people
are doing right like if somebody runs me
over with a car right now and they were
drunk is that my phone was their fault I
get that you can blame that other person
I'm not so much worried about the
actuality of the event I'm talking about
a mindset Tyler when are people that are
still it's the mindset the mindset of
blaming yourself allows you to do so
much more so when it's eight out of ten
times on you you're moving forward
instead of looking backwards sure the
two out of ten but if you just have that
mindset it's just winner mindset is it
my mindset everybody's taking every word
I say so practical yes I understand that
there's issues in the world like it
wasn't your fault that an earthquake
like drill your house I get it it's the
mindset to me I'd be like man I
shouldn't live in California I don't
know like mindset it helps you eight out
of ten times and the other two times you
just deal with it
babban here is all bent out of shape he
just said today is rough to be very
frank with you vaynernation I don't give
a [ __ ] if Tyler or you think today was
rough because I had 17 meetings that he
couldn't be a part of because I'm
actually running a business here
I'm not from some teenage Beauty Bopper
trying to do a vlog or some influence or
doing a blog or some family that's open
for some free detergent because of the
blog I'm working here Tyler so sorry
that your video blog is rough but let me
tell you what's not rough what's not
rough is we're living through the great
era of ground shift in marketing and
business everybody in this amazing town
of New York City which is let me just
tell you everybody who's not here
vibrant at Tenet p.m. right now because
ninety-eight percent of your cities are
sleeping
everybody hears collective pants because
the ground is shifting everything that
our grandparents and parents grew up
with everything that we knew
tried-and-true the stable pillars of
media commerce influence persuasion the
way we make decisions the things we buy
and how what is cool and what is not is
on call
the world is on call and you know what
that means
hustlers the opportunity is obnoxious so
whether you're focusing on vlogs or
influencers or how to have Instagram
stories or how to create alexa voice
skills or how to create your own podcast
as you see i'm full committed till if
you are not following my podcast pissed
the way I call today the the sum up of
all my meetings say none of which you
just watched is that the earth is moving
there's instability in the foundation of
how it was which makes an innovator like
me really happy
and what suffocates all you be players
because you like it like it nice slow
and stable let it be very clear with
this ending rant that game is over and
the people that are gonna win over the
next five to seven years are gonna be
very comfortable in controlled chaos so
you better get your speed up you better
work harder you better work smarter you
better try things you better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at the door
because that slows you down and it
doesn't make you do you better move
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Cameron
Blackwell asked me to if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you would like
me to profile next check out the link in
the description and go and cast your
vote I'd also love to know what did you
learn from this video that had the
biggest impact on you what lesson are
you going to take and immediately apply
it somehow in your life or in your
business leave in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Jose
fellows Jose thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word doing the video showing the review
on Instagram as well
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
treat your business like a second child
nothing is perfect
nothing in business is black and white
all the magic is in the gray have
peaches nothing is the worst thing that
ever happened and nothing is the best
thing that ever happened celebrating
when you've raised money it's just the
beginning being devastated thinking it's
over when we lost the deal is not the
true reality it's always somewhere in
the middle and if you understand how to
raise a second child and realize the
differences of cool it's eating dirt
over there little Timmy's eating dirt
and that's okay that you would have
never left big sister can't do that
that's the same way I think you need to
look at your business nothing is the end
of the world and nothing is the greatest
thing of all time embracing the chaos
embracing the nimbleness embracing the
things that you can't control is the
complete definition of a leader that is
going to be able to navigate through the
chaotic never predictable business world
so relax grab a coffee take a shot of
vodka it's all gonna be okay treat your
business like a second
like for me if I'm in music I wish I
could rap because I know I could be
humongous because all I would do is make
music and then lay in bed for 11 hours
try to hack on social media
get in my recognized notice you're one
person away one piece of content away
you just got to make it and what's
amazing about music and I can't think
everybody I don't like speaking about I
don't know so I don't want to speak to
it but one thing I do know is I believe
that every artist that ever lived had a
lot more songs in their dome than ever
saw the day of life because of the way
it worked right now everybody's fancy
everybody's trying to understand supply
and demand I don't think people
understand how busy the world is the
world so busy there's so much that I'm a
big fan of telling people to put out
music put out music get every week like
if you got it like that you know some
people don't have it I don't know but if
you've got it like that put it out put
it out people are hungry for it and
every time you put out that's giving you
another at-bat I think there will be a
big-time artist in the next decade that
puts out a song a day I agree with that
we did a campaign action called marathon
my bet you got the song mm-hmm some I
saw the reactions today more so than
dropping a hundred i'm telling right now
somebody's gonna wake up and do
something called 365 and they're
starting January 1st and they're gonna
go the thing with me start in this
journey and talent is the bobble was
this big of what I can do but what I've
done and what I've seen is this big
that's right and I've done this very
well and now I'm meeting people like
yourself and other people that I've met
with and they're like oh I'm doing this
I'm doing this I'm like yo I don't even
thought about that and I've been so busy
doing this of course I'm mastering this
that like I mean like no juicing content
selling it to Asia right and it's not
even touching it you get this becomes
available when you become great at
something like this the problem for
everybody right here is they're trying
to do all this before they got great at
this patience patience if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you that sums you Apple so it would
be like a little beacon they believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]